the word it kind of makes people
uncomfortable especially women and that
word is submissive
okay so as a woman as a wife ali what
does it mean to be submissive so the
word submissive has a negative
connotation on it so what would probably
be more digestible for women's ears
would be willful cooperation
if your man has a good program and it's
trusted proven and justified authority
in that relationship authority with
responsibility because he's responsible
for the outcomes of the relationship if
if you have that you're naturally going
to follow and that's the thing about it
is some women talk about you know high
value man high value man there's a lot
of different components to masculinity i
can say for certain that i don't worry
about my physical safety in the presence
of my husband at all he's a strong dude
i met that guy he shook my hand real
strong i was like all right buddy he's a
trained fighter and he's also trained
with weapons so i don't i don't have to
worry about that so of course i'm like
let me let me get with this program this
program is awesome i'd like the
subscription to last for the rest of my
life
and that's what women don't want to hear
but
well because they haven't had experience
with it because i can't keep a man but
uh the thing about submission itself is
that it has a really
convoluted understanding your your man
that you quote unquote submit to willful
cooperation you willfully cooperate with
him he has to have something bigger than
himself that is the goal and some people
break it down to religion like that's
fabulous but i know for my my
relationship my husband is not a
believer but he believes in the greater
good of humanity and society so he's
always trying to do good in the world so
i don't have to worry about him going
mad with power and that's also a weird
narrative that women come up with
they're like well what's going to happen
if you give a manpower like they gave us
wi-fi and air conditioning i think
they're doing great with power well and
because they picked the wrong men to
give power to so they put that on all
men so it's like again they're putting
your poor choices on all of us just
because you can't find a man to submit
to doesn't mean we can't so right and
it's argumentative women that they
struggle with submission because women
that are coming from two parent
households well-rounded i live in the
midwest i know a lot of women that
understand that when there is trusted
proven and justified authority they're
like yes i would like your help i'm
gonna go with the flow on this one but
women just don't want to be honest that
like you're not fun to be around people
are tired of arguing with you people
don't want to people are not fighting
over your invitation at the party they
would rather you didn't go
well and a lot of like more feminine
girls we prefer it like i hate making
decisions like honestly like i hire a
couple people now and like i hate it
it's so against my personality if i
could just have someone like do that
part of the job for me i would prefer it
like it is so much easier as a girl like
working for someone than it is like
having like managing all these people so
she used instead of the word submissive
willful cooperation yes okay i'm so
confused by that term okay so yeah i
mean i would figure you're very
successful yes yes so it would be hard
to imagine applying that work ethic but
in a relationship
i'm still confused do you think you can
explain no break it down so
so do you not understand the wolf of
cooperation or the submission willful
cooperation buffalo
i'm like croatian you know so okay okay
so simple
so basically it's giving your man
authority which is not something that's
often done in society but give me an
example
okay so
you're getting dressed and your dress is
a little bit provocative maybe you're a
little bit ignorant on it he says you
know honey you're showing a little bit
much i don't know if you're aware do you
mind changing like would you argue with
him or would you put on a different
dress if i think the dress looks hot i
would wear it yeah well that's that's
making it about you and not your
relationship that's yeah the opposite of
woeful cooperation okay so yeah that's
not me yeah okay so let's stay there for
a second because um i've dated some
girls that look good in dresses and
maybe they looked a little too good and
i was like you know
the whole honey my does this make my
butt look good hell yeah whatever
whatever
but you're saying
as a man hey babe you know
a little much i don't feel comfortable
with this would you mind changing you
would
change i would absolutely change and
it's not just about the impression that
it would have out there on the world
it's protection because i could get the
wrong kind of attention from an un
unhinged man what would happen if you
get some attention from a man from from
a man that i don't want the attention
from i'm being sexualized by a stranger
i don't want that but what do you mean
by attention to somebody looking at you
that like men are gonna look they always
look so what let them look like i don't
want to be sexualized by someone that's
not my husband
okay so why do you post stuff online
i'm sure some guys watch your stuff
scroll through my instagram
it's pretty kosher like i mean okay
there's some weirdos out there i'm sure
and when you're with a guy you represent
him so i would never want to wear
something that's like embarrassing to a
dude no i agree with that i never like i
would not go i would never wear
something inappropriate for a situation
but if a guy
like i usually tell my boyfriend to
choose my outfits just because he has
good style like he has good taste so
like he would never i'm personally not
like a
vulgar person so what i'm saying is like
if he deemed it inappropriate like like
submitting is trusting his judgment and
so i trust yeah if submitting is
trusting a guy's judgment but then i
agree but but you wouldn't in that
situation because you said no i would
still wear what i want if i felt that my
outfit is appropriate for the occasion
right but that's that's what submitting
is saying even though i think it's
appropriate i'm going to trust my man to
make that decision but is that a
slippery slope right there meaning i
haven't when do the
when does the the submission part
start meaning
we've been dating for three months six
months does it start when you're
official does it start when you're
married meaning if you've only been with
a guy for a couple months and he's like
hey would you mind changing i kind of
get coco's perspective
like i don't know you like that buddy
but if this is a marriage this is your
husband
according to ally go ahead and change
baby are you are you dating with
intention are you dating just just to
date is the question because if define
the difference so if you're dating with
like the expressed intention on both
parties to get married okay like you
have to show him what
like what you're gonna do in the
marriage okay so like some people just
date to have fun and date around like i
can understand not submitting to a guy
if you're just dating to date but if you
want to get married like you have to
show that guy what he's going to get
when he marries you
coco your response no i had a question
for her so i feel like you're a very
family-oriented person right you have a
big family what would happen let's say
you get married to a guy
and five years into the marriage he gets
into a huge fight with one of your
family members and he's like i never
want to go
to your house again what would you do
wow that's a really good question thank
you
um
i wouldn't choose a guy that would get
between me and my family that's not my
question let's say maybe maybe there was
an event maybe people i don't know if
you guys are drinking or not you know
maybe there was a party something's
gonna something happens okay
um if i if he was my husband i would
trust his judgment so you would
you would not speak to your family ever
again because of your husband well you
said one family member okay maybe like
one we can lose there's there's like
like i would like with your dad i see
you're very close to your dad if your
dad gets into a fight with your husband
what would you do if my dad got into a
fight with my husband
um maybe because you were very
submissive and i'm not i don't know
what's your family situation i don't
want to like well i i let my dad vet the
guys that i date actually but so i agree
with that too but things can happen down
the line like five years in maybe maybe
my dad doesn't drink either so it's a
little different okay this is a
hypothetical thing but
like it is
you said it's what i think that's more
of an exception argument well what if
what no but but it's not an if because
relationships and family are going to
fight at the end of the day like i would
if it was my husband i would trust my
husband over my family especially if
that's someone i have a child with okay
like that's that's your husband that's
who you packed
um mean do you feel differently i would
do everything and i would do everything
in my power to like make that work out
um what are your thoughts
uh obviously whatever the situation
would be i would try to use my own
judgment first and i would try to listen
to both sides
but i see a lot in luckily i don't have
this in my family but i hear a lot of
people have issues like oh i hate my
mother-in-law or i can't stand my you
know somebody in my husband's family and
it becomes like a really big issue and
it's always like a
weird situation when you come into
somebody's home if you're not okay with
you know the rest of the family so what
would you do differently how would you
handle that um
i've
i really don't know
like if i get i really don't know
obviously i feel like each of you are
going to go ahead and do a video after
this on this exact topic i look forward
to that
natalie